so one of the fastest growing literary
genres is the genre of
woke leftist children's books
it's like you you walk into the
bookstore now go to the children's
section it's like being at an antifa
rally or something with all these
books the most common subgenre though of
woke children's book is the kind that
pushes gender confusion on children
there are many
adults in this country who want your
child to be
as insane and confused as they are and
that's why they write
books like this this what is called i am
jazz
um uh allegedly co-authored by jazz
jennings who was
at the time this was written a a kid a
boy who
identifies as a girl but really i think
we can safely assume that the real
author is uh
is jessica herthal who's the first
author listed there
i'm told by the internet that jessica
herthal is a straight
ally whatever that means and she travels
the world and she's spreading her gospel
this is her gospel she's spreading it
and speaking to schools and other groups
because yes this book
is read to kids in in school uh so
that's the background on it we'll uh
we'll crack it open and
and see what's inside i suppose i have
to warn you usually when we do videos
like this i like for it to be
sort of funny but this is a brainwashing
tool for children
and uh it makes me too angry to say
anything funny about it so i i'm just
gonna read it and
scream like a crazy person that's
probably the way this is gonna go all
right
i am jazz for as long as i can remember
my favorite color has been pink
my second favorite color is silver and
my third favorite color is green
here are some of my other favorite
things dancing singing
back flips drawing soccer swimming
makeup and pretending i'm a pop star
most of all i love mermaids sometimes i
even wear a mermaid tail in the pool
my best friends are samantha and casey
we always have fun together
we like high heels and princess gowns or
cartwheels and trampolines
all right so you see what's happening
here they're setting the stage uh
explaining why jazz is actually a girl
jazz is really a boy
but they're trying to explain you know
this is why jazz is actually a girl
and of course he's a girl because he
likes mermaids in the color pink
this is supposed to give us an
indication of jazz's true gender except
the problem here
is that we're also told that there is
nothing inherently
feminine about the color pink
or mermaids the the left for years has
been insisting
that it's actually not feminine to wear
a dress there's nothing
that's what they've been telling us
there's nothing feminine about it these
are just uh
social constructs they don't really mean
anything and now they say
if a boy wears a dress he's so feminine
that he must be a girl
so he went from it's not feminine to
wear a dress to
if you do wear a dress it's so feminine
that you turn into a girl
because you wore one so this is
completely incoherent but obviously the
children who
are being subjected to this drivel um
they don't know that it's incoherent and
that's the left's ideas of gender are so
stupid and absurd
uh that they have to indoctrinate you
when you're five years old
before you're informed enough to notice
what's really going on we have a lot
more to read unfortunately
but i'm not exactly like samantha and
casey
i have a girl brain but a boy body
this is called transgender i was born
this way
sure right a couple problems here though
first of all this is really the biggest
problem it makes no sense whatsoever
you see your your brain is your body
okay so drawing a distinction between
your brain and your body
makes no sense it's the same thing
your brain is your body it's like
drawing a distinction between your limbs
and your left arm see if you have a boy
body
then you have a boy brain do you know
how i know
you have a boy brain because you have a
boy body
that's the way it works by definition
but what else could it possibly mean for
a for a boy to have a girl brain
especially because again
we've been told that there's no such
thing as girl brains in boy brains
the left told us that for decades and
now they're saying
oh you know what actually there is such
thing as a girl brain and somehow it can
end up in a boy's body
we don't know how it ends up in there it
just does
when i was very little and my mom would
say you're such a good boy
i would say no mama good girl
at first my family was confused they'd
always thought of me as a boy
as i got a little older i hardly ever
played with trucks or tools or
superheroes only princesses and mermaid
costumes
my brothers told me this was girl stuff
i kept right on playing notice how we
keep going back to mermaid
so mermaid's a fictional character this
has nothing to do with someone's gender
whatsoever
my sister says i was always talking to
her about my girl thoughts and my girl
dreams
and how one day i'd be a beautiful lady
she would giggle
and say you're a funny kid okay so not
only do we have uh girl brains and
boyfriends we have girl thoughts
what's a girl thought you know here's
the thing i don't know what a girl
thought is i guess
because i've never had one because i'm
not a girl
if the term girl thought means anything
it must be
the thoughts that a girl has so you
can't pass possibly have a girl thought
unless you are a girl
which jazz is not sometimes my parents
let me wear my sister's dresses around
the house but whenever we went out i had
to put on my clothes again
this made me mad still i never gave up
trying to convince them pretending i was
a boy
felt like telling a lie then one amazing
day everything changed
mom and dad took me to meet a new doctor
who asked me lots and lots of questions
afterward the doctor spoke to my parents
and i heard the word transgender for the
very first time
that night at bedtime my parents both
hugged me and said
we understand now be who you are we love
you no matter what
this made me smile and smile and smile
okay they they understand now so what
convinced them
well convinced you you didn't understand
before
like your four-year-old or a toddler
comes along and says i'm a girl
and you're the parents and at first you
thought well no you're not
but then he kept wearing pink clothes
any any watched the movie a little
mermaid one too many times and you said
by golly i guess he really is a girl
well what do you know it is no it is no
different
than if your your three-year-old son
comes up to you and says
i'm a doggy and you say no i don't
really think you are doggy and then he
gets down on his hands and knees and
crawls away and you say
wait a second did you see what he just
did well he must be a dog
no there's no way a human could do that
there's no other explanation it's a
miracle
he's a he's a spiritual dog he's a he's
a he's a he's got a dog's brain inside a
boy's body yes
that that's it how absolutely useless
and feckless
do you have to be as a parent to let
your four-year-old convince you that
he's really a girl
how useless and feckless do you have to
be as a parent to let your four-year-old
convince you of anything
i have kids okay i have never been
convinced of anything by a four-year-old
a four-year-old has never said anything
to me that made me go
huh you know you raised a good point
actually i changed my mind
that's never happened to me ever in life
is it because i'm stubborn
maybe so but i think it's because i'm an
adult
okay they're for they don't know
anything there is nothing they can tell
me about anything
that will make me change my mind about
anything
because they don't know anything because
they're for
okay like they just started walking a
couple of years ago
they're barely they they're just now at
the point where they could go to the
bathroom on their own
so no um you don't say to your
four-year-old be who you are
you know why you don't say that because
your four-year-old doesn't know who he
is
he's four doesn't know what a boy is
doesn't know what a girl
is that's why you're there you're the
parent you're supposed to explain
and when your four-year-old says
four-year-old boy says i'm a girl you
know what
your four-year-old boy has no idea what
a girl is
he literally doesn't know what he's
talking about he doesn't know what that
thing it's just a word to him
it doesn't mean anything mom and dad
told me i could start wearing girl
clothes to school and growing my hair
they even let me change my name to jazz
being jazz felt much more like being me
mom said that being jazz would make me
different from the other kids at school
but that being different is okay
what's important she said is that i'm
happy with who i am
being jazz caused some other people to
be confused too like the teachers at
school at the beginning of the year they
wanted me to use the boys bathroom and
play on the boys team in gym class
well what i can't imagine why could it
be because you are a boy
but that didn't feel normal at all i was
so happy when the teachers changed their
minds
i can't imagine not playing on the same
team as casey and samantha
even today there are kids who tease me
or call me a boy name or ignore me
altogether this makes me feel crummy
then i remember that the kids who get to
know me usually want to be my friend
they say i'm one of the nicest girls in
school
i don't mind being different different
is special i think what matters most is
what a person is like
inside inside i am happy
i am having fun i am proud i
am jazz you see it's exactly what i said
uh it just made me angry now i'm just
mad
this video was a mistake like this stuff
in this book
it's not just nonsense right i mean it
is nonsense but
it's it's harmful nonsense because kids
are being brainwashed into it
and their lives are being destroyed you
know jazz jennings is actually
this is a tragic story about jazz
jennings in fact if we lived in a sane
society
and there was a book about jazz jennings
it would be a tragedy is what it would
be
now i think jazz jenny is an adult now
his whole life
has been ruined by his horrible parents
and by the horrible deranged lunatics
who have
done this to him so the whole theme of
this book is be yourself right be who
you are
and i used to think that be yourself was
the dumbest slogan imaginable because
who else are you going to be i used to
think that growing up when i was taught
just be yourself and i would say well
right but who else am i going to be
what other what other option do i have
unless i'm a well i'm a shape shifter
it seems like that no matter what i'm
doing or what i'm being i'm being myself
so it not really helped me out much by
saying that
but now i see that this is actually good
advice because this book is a perfect
example
of a child who has been trained to not
be himself
himself is precisely who jazz is not
being
he's being anyone but himself because
he's been conditioned
to hate himself so our message to a
child who struggles with his identity
our message to a boy
who who struggles to accept that he is a
boy should be
be yourself actually be yourself and you
are a boy and it's wonderful to be a boy
it's a beautiful thing to be a boy you
should embrace that
love it love yourself be who you are you
aren't a she
you're a heat that's okay that's good
be that that should be the message
that's the loving true
real message that you give to a kid this
is garbage
this is noxious poisonous filth and
garbage
so buy this book for firewood if you
want
just don't read it to your kids that's
all i can say